welcome to the Nexus Institute first I'd
like
what do you think makes us stand
and why do you consider its importance
well for me when I think of the word
Naxos I think of a passage and I think
that - how to bring knowledge from one
generation to the other is a thing of
passage and to understand what is
knowledge really is about and why it
concerns something like ethics morals or
basically humanity in a way that
everybody's part of it but we need some
kind of rules and respect for each other
this is what I think it's so important
and how do you think an activity like
the symposium today will help to achieve
such goals
I always doubt that activities like
directly help because I think an
activity like this symposium is people
talking about something that is relevant
to the people sit in the audience and
they think about it themselves they
think about what why they treat
something like education or
communication with younger than others
in their own lives and making people
think is I think the most important
thing symposium ever could wait this
symposium is going to be about building
but do you consider essential building
well the essential building is the
education of the heart because you can
know everything and be a human being
that hurts other human beings and you've
lost everything in that moment so I
think nothing like empathy and respect
and also respect to yourself in your own
abysses and the things who will never
fit together is essential for education
and then of course this idea would
happen centuries and centuries ago and
also what happens in other cultures how
do other cultures solve the same
problems we all have the same problems
of life and their sexuality and work of
food and of spirituality and to have the
courage to learn from better solutions I
think
the goal of Education at this symposium
we also present an issue of our journal
Nexus which contains your contribution
we and we ask you the question
which work of art do you consider
somehow essential for people young
people to learn what would be your
answer well the first I said that would
choose a book and because music and the
arts in which my life books are my life
and books are the perpetuators and
witnesses of paradoxical human nature's
and the teachers empathy and knowledge
and things because I think that the
first step is to regain yourself and
oneself I would choose a philosophical
book of course I mentioned all the
others I did not choose because but I
really want to talk about this love book
but I choose one Seneca the life is
short and in this essay he tries to
remind his friend that the most
important thing is to take care of one's
own soul and to live one's own life and
thereby over the centuries he challenges
the reader to do the same it's a
wonderful choice and a wonderful essay
I'll let you go now but I'll see you one
final question
the motto of the Institute is
understanding through context what do
you think of that is that an important
goal yes I do think so because I think
that we have two things we have the
things I have two space between the
things and Anais Nin ones that we do not
see the things as they are we see them
as we are and understanding the context
from Heisenberg to the phenomenology is
understanding that we cannot see the
thing itself and to reflect the context
is also to reflect otherwise in seeing
it and this is the beginning of
something I would call freedom
you